hello
everybody welcome welcome welcome
we're excited to have you here with us
on ask doc live
now if you are brand new or
if you just need a little reminder
if you're on live with us there is a
chat function go ahead and turn that
chat function on because our amazing
co-hosts will be putting a lot of
information in there for you that you'll
be able to take screenshots of and
referred to later
on products that are going to be
mentioned today ways to get in contact
with us and also
uh valuable information that are just
resources to have on hand
my name is rebecca dukes kozak and i
will be your host for the next two hours
on ask doc live
also if you're on live with us and you
would like to ask dr wallach a question
make sure you find that option to raise
your hand
as i will be calling upon people in
order that their hands were raised i'll
be going back and forth between emails
that we've received also on
askdoclive.com
under contact us or if you're one of our
newsletter subscribers and you receive
the newsletter invitation and you reply
to that with a question i will be trying
to get some of those questions as well
but without further ado
the content of this program is to
provide educational information only on
the importance of nutrition and
supplementation
folks our food supplies are null and
void of what the body really needs in
order to
thrive
we might be surviving
but we deserve to thrive
and the information in this program is
going to share ways that you can do that
naturally
as the body itself is
amazing
it's a creation that has come from this
tiny little cell and multiplied into
what we have today
now the fta requires us to let you know
that our products are not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure any diseases
and this program is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
we always recommend that you work with
your physician because as things start
improving and changing
if you're on pharmaceuticals they're
going to need to be looked at
now
we are honored to have our good doctor
with us who has actually
been very instrumental in suing the fda
with nine victories folks
those victories have led to allowing us
to be able to share this information
with you and also have vital nutrients
added to common food supplies
that were missing what was needed most
now
we do bring good news the genetic theory
if you've been diagnosed with something
genetic as far as the disease goes the
genetic theory has been proven
incorrect
what we put in in our bodies what we
have on our bodies plays a lot into how
our genes are expressed
so
let's give the body exactly what it
wants to thrive and take away the toxins
and that is part of what this program is
going to be sharing with you today
again my name is becca dukes kozak
this show is being sponsored by
askdoclive.com
now on this website we do have a store
we do have all of the replays
from almost two years now
next month will be two years that we
have been doing the ask doc live show
bringing information to you that is
empowering you to make options all on
your own
to better health
if you were invited by somebody specific
to watch this program whether you're on
live or watching the replay make sure
that you get back with them they took
the time and thought of you
enough to share this information with
you to help you find a better health
journey or maintain good health it's not
all about helping six people it's about
making sure that even those that aren't
don't get there
now it is my honor
to be able to
share with you
the amazing
dr joel wallach
welcome dr wallach to ask doc live
well thank you rebecca and thank you for
your team uh you guys are the greatest
and uh thank you for the kind words and
the kind direction you gave a super job
there appreciate it
um well today
uh i've i've collected uh information
this is going to kind of add details to
what we've been talking about off and on
for the last six weeks or so
um
and i'm gonna start out
with uh
we have not done a good job when it
comes to
longevity or lifespan
the you know the medical doctors tell us
we have the greatest health care system
in the world well they are the
healthcare system in the world and
they're looking in the mirror and saying
we have the greatest healthcare system
in the world
um the average lifespan of america the
life expectancy of an american is 75.
the life expectancy of everybody else in
the world is like 85 to 91.
we rank
somewhere between 47th and 54th in the
world when it comes to
life expectancy in the industrialized
world
okay we're doing a lousy job of
longevity
okay and that's because
the medical system has the incorrect
belief that you can get everything you
need just by eating well eat the four
food groups eat the seven food group
pyramid
and get everything you need don't waste
your money on taking quote supplements
unquote
okay that's absolutely 100 incorrect
now
right now everybody agrees upon the
oldest living person
uh on earth
is a lady
uh in south africa by the name of
johanna
mazibuko
johanna mazibuko she was born may 11th
um
in 1894. so this last may 11th she
turned 128. you go to siri and look her
up
johanna mazzibuko m-a-z-i-b-u-k-o
and
she still stays at home she's not in a
nursing home
at 128 and she cleans her own house and
gardens and she walks her
great-great-grandkids to school
and she shops in the local
food markets and stuff like that
and she does use a walker
she
hasn't had any surgeries or anything
like that and she looks like a you know
middle-aged woman
and this is very remarkable and she grew
up on a farm but they didn't grow wheat
by the ryer oats they grew corn
okay and so she stayed away from all the
bad stuff because she lived on a farm
grew up on a farm that didn't have wheat
bran oats they only had corn
which is has no gluten in it okay so
i'll start out there
then we're going to go back to
talking about
three diseases osteoporosis of the skull
and of course we have the book it's all
in your head
okay
and you and i are putting out
a cd okay on this to be the same title
and it's going to be kind of like the
last chapter in the book that's going to
be attached to the book here we're very
excited about that
it's all in your head
because it has a lot of new information
okay
about what's going on in your head
and so we're going to talk about
osteoporosis call we're going to talk
about multiple sclerosis we're going to
talk about
neon beret syndrome
okay well guillain-barre syndrome goes
back to 1916 there were two french
doctors one by the name of geon the
other one called beret okay
and so
they called it the gambere syndrome
because in 1916
now they recognize that teenagers
in france were getting this weird
complex or syndrome really good tingling
and numbness in her feet and in a couple
of weeks it was tingling and numbness
went up to their knees and a couple of
weeks and tingling and numbness went up
to their hips and then up to their neck
and so forth and they'd get paralyzed
and so forth
and about 10 would die
and some were permanently
disabled and some would get better and
worse and better and worse and better
that was kind of the history of this
disease the guillain-barre
syndrome okay
now with that said
let's go to ms multiple sclerosis which
has all the same symptoms here as
gambare syndrome
but
it starts with the i'd say 90 percent of
people who are diagnosed with ms
multiple sclerosis are diagnosed at age
25.
whereas gambari syndrome they're
diagnosed at eight and ten and twelve
and that kind of thing okay
and of course people who were experts
in
uh immense multiple sclerosis said that
kids didn't get it well that's because
they named it a different thing gambera
syndrome okay it's really the same
disease in both cases gambling
syndrome and ms there's a demyelination
process myelin is this insulation
material on the on the cells and also
the nerves in the brain the spinal cord
the peripheral nerves and everything and
it's the insulation material okay
and it's made out of eighty percent fat
and twenty percent protein is myelin now
that eighty percent fat depending on
what part of the brain and nervous
system you're talking about what's the
brain what part of the brain
what part of this the spinal cord and so
on
uh can be 20 percent or 30 or 50 or 75
percent
cholesterol
so who told people to get off of
cholesterol doctors
who mistakenly said the cholesterol
causes plaque in your arteries doctors
okay
and so this is what's going on with ms
multiple sclerosis
okay
and it's kind of interesting women
have three times the rate of diagnoses
of ms in men
women have four times the rate of
diagnosis of osteoporosis including the
skull than men now is this a gender
issue
no
it's diet
okay now rebecca when a girl goes
through puberty and they want to be cute
and chase the boys and have boys chase
them
um
why is it that they start changing their
diet it's their they change their diet
very dramatically because they don't
want to what
they don't want to gain weight they
don't want to gain weight okay and they
want shiny hair and you know they want
beautiful skin and all this kind of
stuff so they're giving up all the bad
stuff according to what doctors say
okay and this is why they have four
times the rate of osteoporosis now both
people
with
uh ms including gambare syndrome
and also osteoporosis of the skull have
celiac disease
celiac disease is a manifestation of
gluten damages the intestines so instead
of your small intestine looking like a
shag rug and all those ville eyes
sticking up
okay to give you a more absorptive
surface
the gluten issue and celiac disease
irritable bowel syndrome
uh you know ibs we're talking about
crohn's disease diverticulitis these
things are all caused by
gluten consumption
and the gluten head makes a poison that
actually kills these villis so instead
of looking like a shag rug when you open
up an intestine at surgery or maybe an
autopsy instead of looking like a shag
rug with all those villi
your lining your intestines look like a
plastic tube you've lost 90 percent of
your
surface so even if you're supplementing
you can't absorb but two percent of it
so it's not enough to prevent and
reverse all these problems okay
so
people have to eat three eggs twice a
day when they're adults when they're
kids when they're babies
even if the mother's got to be doing
that so it's coming through the breast
milk if she's breastfeeding them
okay and that's one of the reasons why
we came up with
um
gosh it's a long story but i just throw
in just two or three minutes of it were
back in
in 1977 i discovered the first non-human
case of cystic fibrosis supposed to be a
terrible birth defect okay in humans it
was in a monkey in the in the nasa
colony
at yerkes primate center at emory
university in atlanta georgia and i sent
the slides of their
liver and
um
pancreas and lungs i didn't tell it was
from a monkey to five medical schools
and i said i think this is cystic
fibrosis what do you think and they all
said a classic example of scissors
and so then i wrote them back and said
hey thank you this is on their
letterhead okay
he said this is actually from a monkey
and so this is the first non-human case
of cystic fibrosis i knew that's what it
was and so thank you this is really
dramatic
and um
um
that we found the first non-human case
of cystic processes at the very least we
have an animal model to study it okay
and so that was good
and then to make a long story short he
said we had all these um
lawsuits and
um
we were all the time petitioning and
petitioning and petitioning in between
the lawsuits to get these nutrients put
into baby formulas and finally we won
nine cases and we finally won 12 cases
and they were forced to
uh put the
uh they've been sort of resisting it for
25 years
okay because doctors would say oh don't
don't put these nutrients into baby
farmers because they're poison it'll
kill the babies and blah blah blah so
these companies were afraid to do that
and so finally the fda forced them
because we won the petitions and
lawsuits so we had so they had to
um follow the nih's direction
and put these nutrients into the baby
farm it wasn't long
just in like 90 days
after that not only did cysterosis go
away but also monstrously went away and
we gave a bunch of of these um
um
records to jerry lewis
and the telethon
and over 50 years he had raised 2.7
billion dollars for the for the telethon
okay for the most physical association
make a long story short he got excited
he took it there and one of our great
associates of marvin robin marine who
was helping me with these must fishy
kids in idaho and utah
um went with jerry and uh they fired the
musculosphere association shut down the
telethon immediately and fired jerry
lewis because they didn't want the news
to get out
that mustachy was not a genetic disease
okay so that was kind of crazy but then
also we got another thing
um suddenly you didn't hear anything
about sediment death syndrome anymore um
you know mothers were supposed to be
laying on their babies and babies
suffocating and there's like 400
american mothers commit suicide because
their families disowned them because the
doctors said they were laying on the
babies and suffocating their babies
these babies are dying of hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease the same
thing as these young athletes died from
a simple deficiency of a single mineral
all these things got put into the baby
formulas and in 1990
um
i see here
in 1990 uh
let's see here
sentiment death syndrome sids
occurred at a rate of
135 to 140 per 100 000
1990 100 000 normal births today it's 15
to 20
per hundred we
per hundred thousand numbers we we
dropped the rate of sediment death
syndrome by 90 or more
just simply by putting these nutrients
into the baby formulas okay so we were
able to prove
unequivocally there was a nutritional
deficiency causing the death of these
babies not the mothers laying on them
okay now did the doctors come out and
say okay we apologize and you know we
have
we have um
our legal systems here so if you feel
like you need to sue us or something go
ahead and do it because you know we will
pay the damages all about no they didn't
do that they just shut up
and skulked away like skunks in the
night
okay
it was a remarkable thing to see
now they've come up with the metabolic
syndrome because they know i'll beat
them up to death if they talk about
genetics if they talk about
autoimmune so now they've come up with a
metabolic syndrome what is the metabolic
syndrome oh obesity diabetes high blood
pressure and heart disease
we've already proven that these things
are just simple nutritional deficient
diseases
okay so this is where we're going
okay i'm very excited about that and we
can we can save lives we can add 25 to
50 healthy years of people's lives i
want our average lifespan to go up to
what oh 128.
oh i thought you were going to say 200
dr wallach okay well 200 is coming
that's our goal here thank you dear all
right now i want to go on to the next
piece here
about six weeks ago
uh u.s government released a statement
we've talked about this before
that um
there's 85 billion dollars spent each
year by pharmaceutical companies
okay
and
health insurance companies
85 billion dollars in the united states
alone each year just to treat the
symptoms
of
ms multiple sclerosis 85 billion i
thought that was terrible which it is of
course
okay
it comes out to forty thousand to sixty
thousand dollars per year per person who
has
ms
forty thousand sixty thousand a year for
each person with ms to pay for their
medication just to relieve symptoms not
to get rid of the disease
now
just about a week ago now
uh the us government came out with
another one saying for type 2 diabetes
type 2 diabetes
let's see here there's uh 324 billion
dollars spent by insurance companies to
relieve the symptoms of type 2 diabetes
324 billion
now you add those two together ms and
type 2 dibs has 400 billion dollars a
year spent just to treat the symptoms of
those two diseases
forty thousand sixty thousand dollars a
year they're spent on each patient
this is crazy
now if they already get on our program
it dropped down to
let's see here
2500 bucks a month if they take it take
our program every day for ms multiple
sclerosis that's their brain
brand heart pack okay according to body
weight and um it's like a little over
200 220 dollars per month that that
beats 40 000.
okay
that crazy and so it's um
and if there's you know if two hundred
dollars a month is too much for you just
take a half a dose every month instead
of a full dose every month
and you'll still be far farther ahead
okay
and then for the um blood sugar issues
type two diabetes it's only 173
175 in their
dollars per month
okay so it's
less than 200 excuse me 2 000 per year
whereas
the you know
the thing with ms multiple closest is 2
500 bucks per year but again you can
take a half of those every month and
you'll be way farther ahead
now
it's one of those things where
this is very simple stuff
and
we can save an enormous amount of money
add 25 to 50 healthy years to your life
and you will be blessed
and you'll save an enormous amount of
money the insurance rate should go down
and that's a very exciting
prediction because
it's like gravity
once you know about gravity it's you
know you're going to predict you jump
off of a 50-story building you're going
to fall down because gravity is going to
pull you down okay you're not going to
be able to just float up there
when you jump over 50 story building
and you can jump off the top of the roof
of your house and you have a two-story
house you know you're jumping off of say
20 feet not 50 stories but you still can
break your leg and break your ribs and
stuff like that you might even die
okay jumping off your roof and so
you know about gravity well
these diseases
are the same as gravity they are they're
caused by nutritional deficiencies now
we came up with a thing for kids even
though the baby is breastfeeding
and this is something
which is very important now because
these baby farmers are difficult to get
you know for like three months or more
six months maybe they've had a trouble
getting the baby farmers
well some years ago we came out with
the kids toddy kids toddy it's a
complete um
liquid tastes good
and i said even though the mother's
breast feeding the baby and she's doing
a good job of staying away from gluten
and taking her 90 cents of nutrients i
want every baby in america they have one
meal a day
from the moment they're born um
in you know one of these
um infant formulas
with the kids toddy and it has a by
weight dosage level on the back label of
the bottle and don't forget the
cherrymans and the efas so they don't
get blood clots and asthma at three
months of age and all this kind of stuff
all these things are very simple
nutritional deficient diseases
and it's just a good thing that we came
out
with this
kid's toddy okay because again
it's been real difficult to get the
the uh formulas they're importing them
from england they're importing them from
germany they're importing them from
france
and i've been looking because they give
the analysis of them and sure enough
they're putting those nutrients in there
so they don't get
uh sentiment death syndrome kind of
thing
okay
and they don't get cystic roses they
don't get muscular history and so that's
a good thing but i still want them to
have our kids toddy the cherrymen's and
the efas one meal a day these are
an add-on for these kids and if you
can't get
some of these uh formulas because they
haven't gotten to your location yet you
can use goat's milk you can use cow's
milk that's what's been going on for
since the beginning of time
okay
but you have to add to it the kids toddy
the cherrymans
and the efas add that to the goat's milk
and the cow's milk and you'll have a
complete
formula for our babies
so it's not a mystery but the doctor
saying don't don't make your own don't
make your own just do nothing wait well
if they waited for three months waited
for six months what are the babies
supposed to eat
okay they're absolutely insane just like
the mothers are laying on the babies and
the babies are in the crib the mothers
are climbing in the crib and laying on
the babies in the crib that's nonsense
okay and so
uh i don't know where these doctors come
up with this stuff well now they come up
with a metabolic syndrome because that
sounds very medical
the medical syndrome because they know
if they talk about something being
genetic or autoimmune i'm going to be on
them and they know that
okay so with all that said
i'm very excited about this
this is
uh we're going in the right direction
and of course it's got to be driven
by the people
it's got to be driven by the people
okay i can't knock on the door of every
office of every medical doctor out there
and um
that's why many years dr milan and we
came out with the book um dead doctors
don't lie we came up with this it was
actually an audio cassette tape to begin
with it became a a cd a dead doctor of
lights in nine languages in california
we saw sell an enormous amount of
spanish
of the cds and also the spanish books uh
dead doctors are alive but all over the
world
we're shipping these books and cds 80
countries
okay
and so it's one of those things where
we're trying to get the information out
there as fast as we can as completely as
we can and as a result of all this work
um in 2015
i became the third person in the world
to get the and be honored with the
lifetime achievement award for natural
medicine and philanthropy from the
united nations in august of 2015. very
very proud of that and here's a picture
of me at their offices in new york city
receiving that award
okay
and
i i'm breathless so finally somebody
recognized that we're doing something
good
to help the world's children and it's a
blessing
so and if you don't have any experience
with nutrition we do have the set the
truth about nutrition the book the cd
the dvd
and um it's a college education in that
set
okay you'll get more information in that
set the truth about nutrition the book
the cd and the dvd it comes as a set the
three pieces
and
you'll get more information
about nutrition and the diseases that
they can prevent reverse
than you would by going to a nutrition
class
in high school or in college
okay over to you rebecca
all right thank you so much dr walek
there is
so much information that is not
being
shared
and folks
if you hear it
you are part of
the tribe
the family that needs to share this
information
with others
you're not going to hear it anywhere
else they're not going to hear it if we
don't share it
and if we love somebody would it why
would you keep something
that could save their life or at least
give them the opportunity
of having a better quality of life
i wouldn't i couldn't
you know whenever i found dr wallach and
his programs
um i got great results they continued to
to get better and better and
this is part of my thank you to dr
wallach in hosting this program and
making sure others get the information
as well
we can't thank you and your team enough
because you have a far reach
and um
uh it's quality information and so i
applaud you and your team thank you so
much
well i love and appreciate my team
that's john jonty mccollier nasima omar
ruth ellen sanchez
heather bowen and dr judy reynolds we
are here
because
dr wallach we believe in and support
your mission and helping others get
information on how they themselves can
be more empowered
and folks if you're on with us live make
sure that you have that chat on
they are putting some valuable
information in that chat to help you
get an idea of
what we're talking about because
dr wallach
he speaks fast
so
taking notes
i even have a hard time and i've been
listening to him for seven over seven
years now
so i encourage you to turn that chat on
and you can find the replay to all of
our programs again on askdoclive.com
[Music]
if you're on live with us go ahead and
raise your hand we have a few hands up
right now that we're going to be getting
to dr wallach
and let's just see how many we can get
in today i love helping people and
oh
wonderful we have people that have sent
in questions and have uh called and left
messages
with their hands up so this is the best
place to get your answers right from the
doctor himself
so first
let's go to and forgive me is it zaynab
go ahead and unmute yourself
yes it is zainab thank you you know
awesome welcome and you're on live with
dr wallin
thank you so much
yeah so i am a heart attack survivor i'm
eight weeks into recovery
and um right now i've been prescribed
what they call the heart attack cocktail
of like
uh 12 to like six drugs
and um i'm just wondering if there are
ways of addressing um my recovery
through nutrition as opposed to
these prescription medicines
how old are you
and how tall are you five four
and how much you weigh
230.
okay at 5'4 i'd like to see you weigh
maybe
um
[Music]
uh 120 130 so you're maybe 100 pounds
overweight
okay
and then now when you had your heart
attack was it a blood clots was it
coronary artery disease
um it was lots it was clots i had one
stent put in and they didn't there's
still some blockages there that they did
okay
okay do you have any other issues any
highlight pressure or diabetes
i do not uh it's obesity and uh
lower body arthritis
so you have you have some bone issues
from the waist down or from mid back
down
yeah
okay do you have any ringing in your
ears
no
any dizziness or balance problems
only from the medications
okay
now how many times a night you wake up
to go urinate
uh right now i don't do that i used to
do that prior to the heart attack uh at
least once a night okay
all right so the medication has put a
damper on that okay
are you taking medication for the
arthritis
uh only supplements
okay good okay well here we go
um to 230 pounds i need to lose 100
pounds so i want you to get our one meal
a day our keto shake comes in strawberry
chocolate
it's a meal replacer it's not to add two
meals it doesn't matter it could be any
meal
today could be lunch tomorrow could be
dinner time it doesn't matter
but it's a meal replacer not to add to a
meal and then i want you to drink with
that one or two or a rebound a rebounds
four shrink has
75 minerals
and 25 vitamins amino acids it's not an
energy drink like red bull which is
nothing but caffeine and sugar okay our
our our sports drink as we call this
forest drink instead of an energy drink
okay
because ours is more
of
a support of every system in the body
so
in addition to that
i want you to take two healthy brain and
heart packs per month two healthy brain
and heart pattern month to photos
everything twice a day i want you to
take two bottles a month of our msm
and uh take three of breakfast street
lunch dinner time and they will support
and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
bone itself rebuild everything that's
the msm then i also want you to have
our uh let's see here uh beyond osteofx
go ahead and take uh
let's see here uh two servings a day
that one at breakfast one at dinner time
it comes in liquid comes in capsules
comes in powder so you can decide which
way you're going to do it okay that's
the
um
let's see here then i also want you to
take our collagen peptides get a
canister that powder doesn't have any
taste but it is the collagen
um
connective tissue and and disc and
um bones and
tendons and ligaments from fish poultry
sheep and and cattle okay i want you to
take a scoop of that in your breakfast
drink and scoop without your evening
drink i also want you to have
um two bottles a month of our vitamin d3
so you can take
three d3 at breakfast and three d3
at dinner time so you can absorb these
things
and to help rebuild your bones and
connective tissue and so forth and
you'll lose about a half a pound of two
pounds a day on this program
and you have to just consciously
any time
when people get 100 pounds overweight
it's because they're nutritionally
deficient they develop a behavior called
pica and even though you're eating a
nice dinner
see i better have another helping of
everything i'm still hungry because when
you're missing nutrients your body
develops this behavior called pica and
you keep looking for that nutrient
that's missing and so you're eating more
eating more anymore looking for that
food that's why people become obese you
take these nutrients you take the and
you find that one
or three or five whatever it is they're
missing then suddenly now
hey you're not finishing your
plate well i don't know i'm just not
hungry anymore and you'll lose a half a
pound of two pounds a day without any
effort on your part
okay very very quickly
all right so give us a call every couple
of weeks because you're going to have a
great story
now we deal literally thousands of
people every day all around the world
with the same issue
and so you're going to have a great
story we have a lot of experience with
this
so give us a call
every week or every two weeks however
you want to do it and let us know what's
going on because your story will help a
lot of people
okay and and
um pronounce your name for me again
zainab
dana
zainab oh zainab okay
all right very good okay zayn i will
look forward to hearing from you soon
god bless
thank you
okay
[Music]
um so
you know doc you are completely right
when you give your body the nutrients
that it needs it does not feel like it's
in a constant non-stop starvation mode
anymore
yeah and if you have personal experience
i have how much is my experience okay
how much
you're very beautiful now okay and i'm
sure you were beautiful before what are
you talking about
no
i'm getting better with sage that's for
sure
and how much and how much weight did you
lose on the program i've lost 100 pounds
wow
it is you have an amazing story and so
your story
gives hope to so many people so thank
you for sharing
absolutely well it it's my honor dr
wallach and
you know i feel it part of my obligation
to society
to say hey
there are options
we do not have to depend on a system
that's failing us
yeah and then for a nutritional
deficiency they don't do bypass surgery
okay
they want to do drugs
to try and solve a problem it's a
nutritional deficiency problem and this
is why they have failed and that's why
they have given up the terms autoimmune
and genetic and they're going to the
metabolic syndrome
that sounds very doctory okay
metabolic
but what does that mean exactly
i don't know well oh go go ask your
doctor right
your blood sugar's all out of whack all
of your cells are not functioning the
way they're supposed to they're breaking
down your body is breaking down and um
yeah just take this peel it's a chemical
it'll mask all those symptoms and
you know forget about it well
no
it didn't work for me dr wallach
so but let's
let's continue to share the information
that does work okay
john has a question in regards to
fasting what is your opinion on fasting
just on a regular basis not even
based on you know religious
fasting for for specific days
okay
well in general
i'm i'm not big on fasting okay
because you need whether you're sleeping
or you're working physically your body
needs these 90 essential nutrients in a
constant stream
24 7 to to have optimal health and add
25 to 50 healthy years your life so you
can spend 25 to 50 more years with the
people you love and so forth okay
when you fast
you're talking about
a thought that goes back
hundreds if not thousands of years ago
because people didn't feel good
and they would stop eating for a couple
of days
and they call that fasting and they felt
better and they started eating again
then they felt bad again so they would
fast you know say three days a month or
something like that and they would feel
better for three or four or five days
but then all the bad stuff would come
back every time they started eating
again
well this is because they were
nutritionally deficient
and um you know who knows what was going
on they probably had 15 different
diseases or more
and um
so the old days weren't really as good
as people said okay
and so fasting
now for religious reasons that's
a different story
but for just on a routine health basis
uh no i i see no value in fasting
okay thank you so much
now we have some people that um whenever
they do fast they continue to take their
supplements is that okay
yes
and that's a much better way if you're
gonna if you're not gonna eat meals
continue to take your supplements just
take it with water
or
you know something like
our liquid rebound or something like
that
and so that's fine
but you do have to continue to take your
your
um
required nutrients okay
it's one of those things where there's
not a single moment of the day
you can be without these things
if you're going to have maximum benefit
for health
i agree i agree thank you dr wallach for
sharing great question john
let's go to stacy who has her hand up
stacy go ahead and unmute yourself
joining us from far lands
on the other side of the country
welcome stacy
thank you thank you very much
hi yes i did i apologize i didn't get
that where are you from
well i'm actually an american but i live
in sweden
okay so you're calling us from sweden
right now
yes
okay good how can we help you stacy
yes um i have seen a health issue on my
arms and on my legs where the pigment
like these white type of i don't know
that there's sunspots or whatever where
the pigment is um
you know not the same it's just this
white type of spots and then i also have
on my right toe i'm starting to feel
um
like a burning
burning sensation as well
okay do you hear me ringing in your ears
any tinnitus
no not that i know
okay well you'd know it okay any
dizziness or balance problems
um
no i've had i've had in the past low
blood pressure but it's been going up
recently
okay how much you weigh and how old are
you
i weigh 147 pounds i am 57 years old
how tall
five eight okay do you have a great
white or silver hair
uh yeah i have i have some yes
okay yes do you color your hair no
okay
all right well these white spots are
called vitiligo
okay this is
the same cause it's caused by the same
thing that causes white hair
white hair silver hair gray hair is not
caused by aging it's due to nutritional
deficiency and some people get vitiligo
with it and some people don't okay and
so
at 147 pounds
uh do you have any highway pressure or
diabetes
no
um
no i yeah
my pressure's a little bit higher it's a
little bit higher than it used to used
to be very low so yeah okay um do you
have anything going on um
like anemia anything like that
okay okay good
all right what about your bowels you
have constipation diarrhea i've been
having constipation recently but when i
usually when i drink water i it usually
goes away but i've been
yeah i've been on the kato diet now for
like a month and a half okay
and then
also
uh let's see here
have you ever been diagnosed with
anything like um
crohn's disease or celiac disease or
irritable bowel syndrome or anything
like that i i uh no
not diagnosed and i've had issues with
gluten so
that is an issue um but i've been off of
it for a week a month and a half
okay good yeah you have to stay off of
it forever everybody's associated with
it they got to get rid of it so that
you're not getting cross-contaminated
okay well here we go you need to get rid
of all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat nobody rhinos no sugar
no carbonation even the diet drinks need
to go because the carbonation diet
drinks still neutralize your stomach
acid so you can't absorb minerals and
digest food so that's very important
and then
at 147 pounds i want you to have and
this is for our listeners all over the
world too i want you to take two healthy
brain and heart factor month two healthy
brain and heart factor a month the
photos thing twice a day once you get
two bottles a month of our um let's see
here
uh of our msm so you can take three
breakfast food lunch at dinner time and
they're going to support and promote
mains repair of cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone ranks the bone cell
skin
also
okay and also the hair will be involved
here
and then i want you to take our collagen
peptides
okay which is collagen from fish and
poultry and sheep and beef i want you to
take a scoop of that with your morning
drinks without your evening drink
i also want you to take our hair skin
and nails take three of those twice a
day there's two bottles a month the hair
skin and nails
and then i want you to take vitamin d3
uh three at breakfast for eating lunch
it's gonna be three breakfast three at
dinner time there'll be two bottles a
month of our vitamin d3 so you can
absorb these minerals and put them in
the right place
and this burning situation in your toes
and so forth will go away the vitiligo
goes away very quickly
your hair color comes back so you know
you're absorbing the nutrients yeah yeah
and i i have people who've been with me
for 30 40 50 years they're 80 90 years
old they look like they're 40 then they
don't color their hair they used to have
gray hair but their hair came in their
normal color whether it's red or black
or brown or blonde or whatever it was
that comes in and all their skin issues
go away
and so it's definitely worth doing this
stuff because it's going to add 25 to 50
healthy years your life and the benefit
of that is you get to spend 25 to 50
healthful years of the people you love
okay so that's the benefit you get for
doing everything right and do give us a
call every couple of weeks because um
people want to hear whatever happened to
that american
uh who's
was
in switzerland in sweden in sweden
okay
thank you very much thank you stacy
let's see here rebecca we got time this
hour let's uh let's go into another
caller
all right well let's let's go to a
question that came in from michael dr
wallach
michael says dear dr wallach i have been
listening to you for years and using
many of your recommendations regarding
supplements for various elements over
the years
i have suffered with ocular migraines
for over 35 years on the average of one
episode every three months
initially triggered mostly by bright
sunlight
over the last four months the episodes
have become more frequent at about
once every two to three weeks but
usually milder and of shorter duration
than the previous ones
i've been under a lot of stress lately
but certainly foods such as dark
chocolate may be playing a role
apparently
the cgr peptide not sure what that is
you might
seems to be the cause of these abso
episodes according to some articles any
suggestions on
cause and natural treatment options dr
wallach
now i love the fact that he asked for
cause
because you can put a band-aid on
something and not address the cause and
you're really not taking care of the
issue
okay well migraines are these terrible
headaches you know behind your eyes in
your head kind of stuff
and they're caused by squeezing of the
fifth cranial nerve the trigeminal nerve
okay
and it's called
trigeminal neuralgia
uh
okay
kind of thing
but migraines are the street name for it
okay
and this is caused by osteoporosis
called squeezing the fifth cranial nerve
okay
i guarantee he's got tinnitus ringing
the ears he may have trouble swallowing
because the glossopharyngeal nerve the
ninth trailer being squeezed and so on
and
it's one of those things where
um
it's
i see this
literally a thousand times a day
all over the world 80 different
countries people call me
by the hundreds every day with these
problems
okay obviously opposed to the skill
that's why we have the book
it's all in your head
okay
okay and you and i are coming out with
this cd that's going to go along with
this book by the same title it's on your
head so the cd
is remarkable we listened to it last
night it's just i think it's really one
of the great major jumps forward in our
health care
regimens
is that cd because it's something you
listen to when you're driving your car
you can listen to it on
a computer with a whole family listing
at the same time you can discuss it
but he didn't get see and people don't
give me their weight how old they are
how tall they are what other diseases
they have
and you know they expect me to give them
all this information well it just so
happens that i know a lot about
migraines because they're a
manifestation of the fifth cranial nerve
being squeezed there's 12 pairs of
cranial nerves
and they don't
actually get squeezed at the same rate
on right side and left side so you can
have more migraine headache on the right
side
and then the left side or more on the
left side than the right side sometimes
it's equal but rarely is it equal okay
and so
per 100 pounds of body weight that's all
i can do here per 100 pounds of body
weight
i want to take one healthy brain and
heart pack per month got to get rid her
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat bread around those no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
gotta go
and then there's one healthy brain and
heart pack per 100 pounds of body weight
into an adult man i would suspect he's
going to have to take two healthy brain
hard packs for a month the full dose
running twice a day i also want him to
get two bottles a month of our msm so he
can take three of those at breakfast
street lunch for dinnertime
and
they are
sources of collagen
okay
and minerals to help rebuild connective
tissue okay and of course we're talking
about
everything from
bones and joints and cartilage and
ligaments and tendons and connective
tissue in the walls of arteries and
veins and skin and so on
okay then i want them to have the
collagen peptides i'd take a scoop of
that in your morning drink and scoop
with that in your evening drink michael
okay
and then
that deals with the immune system the
bone marrow the bone matrix also tendons
and ligaments and cartilage
vitamin d three three of those twice a
day
uh again again i'm kind of shooting for
200 pounds here anything over 150 pounds
i go for 200 pounds
and then um let's see here
also
for the
pain inflammation
i like the btt 2.0 tablets and are
kilobiotic a killer biotic is a
collection of mushrooms including the
rishi mushroom which are legendary for
supporting the immune system and
anti-inflammatory take three of those
twice a day
and then
the btt 2.0 tablets
they're not the same as the powder btt
2.0 powder
is
the
essential
minerals okay and powder form and
vitamins and amino acids and powder form
whereas the tablet again is designed to
support the immune system and is
anti-inflammatory
and so you could take three of those
twice a day i do that just
because i'm 83 years old so i take three
of the killer biotic twice a day and i
take three
of the btt 2.0 tailless
twice a day in addition to all my
healthy brain and heart packs and msm
and collagen peptides and vitamin d3 and
so on
so um
he needs to contact us
live
and at any rate he can get started here
he will pay wholesale prices for the
products he gets on auto ship i will pay
the shipping thing any better than that
and so i'm always very excited about
being able to help
people with
simple problems if you go to a doctor
they're going to put you on drugs which
may mask the symptoms for a while
but the disease keeps getting worse and
worse and worse you wind up instead of
having one or two manifestations of
obviously approach to the skull within
six months to two years you'll have
20 manifestations of osteoporosis to the
skull
okay
and so it's one of those things where
get on it michael okay because this is a
totally reversible stuff
okay all right thank you dr wallach
one product that i added that helped a
lot in addition to which
you mentioned is stress oh de-stress
yeah two twice a day
i love de-stress
yeah well de-stress is great and it
gives the brain
a lot of stuff that it needs for just
daily metabolism but also it's designed
for people with congestive heart failure
take three of those twice a day and get
rid of all the bad foods including
gluten and everything so you can absorb
the stuff take your healthy brain and
heart pack add the de-stress to it add
the synaptic to it and congestive heart
failure goes away
okay you don't need
surgery and that kind of stuff for
congestive heart failure you don't need
valve replacements and all this kind of
stuff you know give us a couple of weeks
and you'll see oh my gosh
and see what the doctor says
okay the doctor said well okay yeah you
don't need the surgery now but um please
don't come back here anymore
because he doesn't want you sitting in
the waiting room telling your story to
all the other people
there you go
um dr wellick we're coming up here on on
time for a
break we've got a few minutes but i do
want to make a public service
announcement everybody we appreciate all
of you being on and we love seeing your
smiling faces with your cameras on
but there are a few people that we've
had to turn your cameras off
because
you don't quite have the appropriate
attire for public appearance so please
when you're joining us make sure that
you have clothes on
your shining faces and
not the moon so
everybody
just
and you know there might be some people
that don't even think about it don't
even realize when you jump on a zoom
that your camera is automatically on
unless you say to turn it yeah you're
you're showing off to a hundred thousand
people
you know
like we want to keep this as a family
appropriate
clean program
um that everybody can enjoy dr wallach
because well thank you you're a family
man
that's true you've been and you've been
helping families around the world for
how many years now
75 years
75 years folks
since he was just a boy
yep yep i started helping people it's
kind of interesting um
the church they noticed that i wasn't
this mean disruptive kid
uh on you know sunday mornings anymore
um helping people up steps and i'm doing
all that kind of stuff
and they're watching me and couldn't
figure out why i had changed so much and
finally after a couple months i had one
little old lady come up to me and said i
hear you can cure diabetes and i said
ma'am i'm only nine years old i don't
even know what diabetes is
but i realized
that people were recognizing that i had
changed
i had changed dramatically
okay from somebody who's disruptive and
so forth and i figured that out on my
own because they forced me to 20 doctors
my parents
our family doctor had sent me to 20
different pediatricians who dealt with
kids with behavioral problems 20
different doctors over a five-year
period and i only got worse and worse
and worse and worse and they gave me
talk therapy and all that kind of stuff
um i refuse to take their drugs
okay but when when i was nine years old
uh they're gonna and
put me in a
an asylum of some kind and i didn't like
the sounds of that and so
um while i'm sitting there on friday
night
um
my parents are packing my bags 20
doctors that failed they're going to
take me on monday to this institution
and i had asked them well how long am i
going to be in there and they say well
maybe for the rest of your life because
until they figure out what you got well
i didn't sound good to a nine-year-old
so
on saturday morning
okay i go out to the barn
and i
got the alfalfa pellets okay that had
been
fortified with vitamins and minerals and
i threw out the cheerios and the
wheaties to the chickens
and put those alfalfa pellets in my
cereal bowl put milk on them so i had
the alfalfa pellets on saturday sunday
and monday morning and by monday
afternoon i was cured after five years
of disruption and 20 doctors couldn't
figure it out but and so i knew when i
was nine years old there was something
in those vitamins and minerals that i
was missing causing my behavioral
problems
i was only nine years old so that's when
i figured it out and began to i'd start
going and looking up diabetes and
looking up high blood pressure and
looking up arthritis and i'm saying boy
they were missing a lot here why are
they missing so badly these are doctors
they should know this stuff
and so i i was seeing a stream
of church people coming to me constantly
when i'm only nine years old
because i was healing them
wow and dr wallach
it's not that hard is it
no it's difficult of course uh the first
book let's let's play doctor of course
uh for public stuff as is written in
kind of like the sixth grade reading
level and then of course um my thesis
because and people say well why did you
get that 25 million dollar grant you're
just a dumb kid
okay well that's because i ran into the
first mass style from pollution in
america
okay as a student in in veterinary
school
okay and i was working my way through
veterinary school by working in the
pathology department it was december
um this year it was december of um i'll
be done in two minutes here december
of um
uh let's see here
oh
1963.
they were all fall off on christmas
holiday and i'm doing the autopsy myself
this farmer comes in with 50 dead lambs
and he said um i had 500 dead this
morning
what
500 dead he said yeah last night i fed
them and they're all good
they're all good and um you know lambies
and they're doing their bad bad ass
stuff and running around hopping in the
feed bunks and chasing each other around
and i fed them like i was doing in a
couple of weeks they're going to go to
to slaughter i was feeling kind of bad
about that this morning i went up to
feed him again and all 500 were dead
okay and so i asked him well
what fertilizer to use well i don't i
just buy everything for my neighbors who
fertilize and to use and so he cut these
lambs open and their blood was bright
cherry red which means they were getting
nitrates
and so he did find out that this guy was
using like 10 times more nitrates than
he should have because he wanted to sell
more tons and bushels per acre okay it
was flowing into the pond that these
lambs were
were getting their water so why did they
all die in one night instead of one die
tonight and then two weeks later another
two die and kind of stuff so why did
they all die one night
well i checked the weather system and
sure enough the temperature had dropped
and this is central missouri in the
wintertime
it can be 50 60 degrees in central
missouri
but then at night the temperature
dropped to 16 and they all died of
hypothermia
okay i got it published in 1965 when i
went to africa just as i was leaving for
africa it got published in veterinary
journals
and when i was there for two years
working the white rhino project
the marlin perkins used that paper
to get a 25 million grant from nih they
called me back to be the pathologist on
the subject because they use my
papers to get that 25 million dollar
grant
i was only you know like
um
i think what 18 years old
wow
and that just is a great reminder dr
wallach plants
they need three nutrients
mammals
we need 90
we cannot thrive
or even survive if we don't get what the
body actually needs yes and those
nutritional minerals occur in veins like
gold and silver so they don't occur
uniformly all over the earth so you do
have to take them
as essential
factors
and intentionally and
you know as your research has found
you've discovered what the body needs
based on looking at okay what's missing
and that disease is that's associated
with what is missing that is correct you
get an a plus here and that's where you
came up with is it over 600
different diseases that are directly
linked to nutrient deficiencies you got
it you got an a plus plus so folks you
know it's not
difficult when you when you hear it
it's like oh wow why didn't i think of
that that makes so much sense but unless
you hear it you don't know
and that's why this program is being
brought to you to share with others feel
free to share this with others
askdoclive.com
you will have all of our replays
critical health news
youtube page we have all of our replays
that makes it so easy
to be able to share this information
with others and i think it's rumble also
we're also on rumble is that correct
jaunty
um for critical health news
so critical health news uh youtube
channel is uh you you can you can find
everything there i'm out go to
askdoclive.com and keep it simple
well keep it simple health is simple
let's just keep that simple too thanks
donkey see
you're the best well everybody let's go
ahead and take a break so get up and
stretch move around get some movement
we will be right back with a stock live
and again
if somebody shared this program with you
please get back with them
and say hey thanks for sharing that
information with me i learned some
things that i hadn't thought of before
and i want to get on a program can you
help me
if they specifically can't help you i'm
sure they know somebody that can
and if you were not referred to this
program by anybody specific or
through any type of communications
then
feel free to go to askdoclive.com
we have a store there we have
most popular books by dr joel wallick
and we also have a contact us where you
can get in
contact with a certified holistic health
coach that can help you find the best
protocol to meet your specific needs we
will be right back with ask.live
all right thank you so much everybody
for hanging out with us
as dr welch is getting back on there he
is
go ahead and unmute yourself doc
and we're going to go to the next hand
that is up
perfect all right
and the next hand we have with us
deborah debra
go ahead and unmute yourself
you're on live with dr wallach hi doc
hello deborah
how can we help you i have uh two i have
some clients and two things are coming
up that i would like some input on
one is uh those that are adamant about
being a vegan
and what we need to do to support them
and then the other is this chronic
hydrotherapy
where they're flushing the colon with
water
okay
well vegans are in trouble
especially if they eat gluten
okay
plants cannot manufacture minerals
plants require three minerals
we require 60.
nutritional minerals do not occur in a
uniform blank around the crust of the
earth they occur in veins like gold and
silver okay
so you can have plants that look very
nice
okay but only have three nutrients in
them
okay so being a vegan is not good now
being a vegan
back a thousand years ago was okay maybe
in some places not all places but in
some places it was okay because they
used wood ashes which were minerals
they were left when you burnt the wood
in the wood stoves and the fireplaces
and fire pits they use the wood ashes
for
um
fertilizer
my grandma used to put wood ashes until
we were nine years old we didn't have
electricity so we had wood ashes in our
soup and our stew
had okay we had our sweet potatoes we
had
wood ashes in just about everything
and we were getting minerals that way
whatever minerals were in the salt where
we got the wood and the coal from okay
and so we put the ashes in our food and
in our gardens
and i'm only four or five years old and
my job was to put the wood ashes in
between the rows of onions and tomatoes
and
squash and stuff like that in our
gardens every day from our wood stoves
and fireplaces but then when i was nine
years old we went to electricity we
didn't have anymore yay
i didn't have to do that anymore okay
and so that's very very bad okay you
have to take the essential factors
okay these things are not a choice
um and so that's why you don't see
vegans living to be 120.
i'm gonna have to find out what the
average lifespan of a
drop dead
vegan somebody who's been a vegan all
their life
what's their average life expectancy of
a vegan compared to
you know a uh somebody who's taking
the essential factors
every day to make sure they get
everything okay so that's my thing on a
vegan
if you want to be a vegan you better be
taking your 90 essential nutrients i
mean big time
okay
and um this is why we have
the the
collagen peptides this is why we have
the msm this is why we have the
healthcare heart pack the other random
heart pack has 215 nutrients in it
including the 90 essentials
and so if you want to be a successful
vegan you know don't want to eat big
bloody piece of red meat steak and ribs
and all that kind of stuff and chickens
and things don't do it
but you do have to eat eggs
okay because you need the cholesterol
for your brain otherwise you're going to
get ms
okay
you're going to wind up with all kinds
of terrible diseases if you
don't eat those eggs
what you think about an egg
you incubate it for 26 days and a chick
pecks out of it
now that egg that chick started out is a
little one millimeter diameter flat disc
on top of the yoke that's that little
white spot on top of the oak that's the
chick
and incubating for 26 days that little
white spot
hatches
it comes out it's got a beating heart
and all the blood vessels everywhere
it's got lungs it's got liver kidneys
it has a digestive system it has a brain
and eyes
has muscles and bones and cartilage and
ligaments and tendons has a digestive
system
all from that one little white spot
because all the nutrition is in that
yolk and the white of the egg
just think of
how much nutrition is in that egg to
create that that live chick from that
little white spot
okay is one of the good lord's miracles
the same thing is true for only chickens
but also for ducks and geese and
ostriches and
wombats and
mongooses everything that lays eggs okay
um whether they're a mammal or a bird of
some kind
or or even a uh reptile okay
amphibians they lay eggs too
um and then
um
hydrotherapy you know you're drinking a
lot of water um that's fine as long as
you're taking
your essential factors
okay
but don't think see the reason why
people used to do hydrotherapy and
they'd go get enemas once a week or
something like that from some
hydrotherapist and so on because they're
eating gluten and they're constipated
their villi are dead their intestines
are losing 90 of their absorption
surface
and let's look at people who get
hydrotherapy how long do they live
that's that's the ultimate question you
have to ask
okay
let's get a hydrotherapist on here and
say okay what's the average lifespan
of a patient who's come to you or a
client who's come to you they don't even
have any diseases but they're doing
hydrotherapy
and do they come to you for 20 years 50
years 100 years
i don't know a
hydrotherapist or average lifespan is
only 55. well that's not a good signal
okay and so
many of these things
came into play
because of
um people who
uh ate meat got
diseases that were
found in cows and sheep and and so forth
okay so they didn't want to get those
diseases so they started just eating
vegetables they weren't eating
um
cows that are dying of the plague or
something like that okay
same with hydrotherapy
the odds are it started because people
were having gluten problems they were
constipated they need to have a enema
you know twice a week or three times a
week or every day
otherwise you know they'd be 25 pounds
overweight with bowel movements piling
up in their intestines and so forth
because of gluten
there's reasons why people came up with
those
uh procedures
but and and habits
but that doesn't mean it was right okay
um and so it's one of those things where
if you know why they are doing them
do you need to do them okay
if it's doing it for religious reasons
that's a different story but still
if you're fasting and doing hydrotherapy
and being a vegan for religious reasons
you better be taking your essential
factors i mean big time
otherwise you're going to be a bad
example because you're not going to live
as long as people who are not
okay so i hope that answers the question
yes it does thank you sir you're very
welcome
deborah did you have another question
no that was both of them oh the queen in
the coleonic cold clowning there we go
awesome thank you so much
found dr wellick let's just go ahead and
move on to our next hand that is up
terry
go ahead and unmute yourself
i'm sorry didn't you get that name tear
it was it terry
terry
terry okay with a t
hey terry okay
hi good morning hi
so how can i help you
i'm calling concerning my son
who is on medication for mental deficits
and basically he hears voices so
i would say he's depressed with
schizophrenia
and i was wondering what kind of
supplements he could take to help his
situation okay how old is he
31.
okay
and how much does he weigh do you know
about
about 250.
okay how tall is he 62.
okay
does he have any other issues have a
pressure diabetes arthritis back
problems anything like that he has a
back problem because he got in a
motorcycle accident
okay get vertebrae
i'm sorry you broke up there say that
again about his very ray he he broke his
l2 vertebrae okay okay
all right
now
you have to appreciate that your brain
requires
essential nutrients
okay
and so the first thing you have to do is
get rid of any interference and you know
somebody who's
a 6-2
okay 6-2
i'd like him to weigh he could weigh 180
to 200 pounds so he might be maybe
30 pounds overweight kind of thing
30 40 pounds overweight
okay so i want him to get one
of the keto
shakes meals per day
okay now these are not to add to a meal
these are a meal replacer okay and he
can have two of the rebound drinks with
that
keto shake to come in strawberry and
chocolate
all right and he'll lose a half a pound
of two pounds a day then also at 250
pounds i want them to have two healthy
brain and heart packs per month
now let me go back up here you need to
get rid of all the bad foods again no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no gluten no we brought around oats no
sugar no carbon carbonated drinks even
the diet one's got to go and i apologize
for having to go through those again but
this is for all of our listeners you
know yeah
you on coast to coast so
okay
okay you've heard the story before yeah
okay then he needs two healthy brain
heart packs for a month to full dose
everything twice a day
okay then he also has 215 nutrients in
the healthy brain heart pack 215
nutrients including the 90 essentials
that everybody agrees upon
then he needs um
two bottles a month for msm you can take
three breakfasts from lunch at dinner
time they're designed to support and
promote mainstream pair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone rings
bone itself
you also need to take
um
three eggs twice a day with soft yolks
fried eggs won't count hard-boiled eggs
don't count they're gonna be soft
yolks okay soft boil soft yolk soft
poached soft yolk soft sauce scrambling
butter that's how i have mine i had my
three this morning okay with rice
and um
i had tuna
okay from alaska
with my breakfast
and my eggs
with soft yolks and so forth then i had
of course
all of my
products and so forth and you know
that's kind of my sort of system
sometimes i'll have a tuna
sometimes i'll have salmon sometimes
i'll have a hamburger sometimes i'll
have a steak with breakfast kind of
stuff
okay along with along with my um other
things that i have every day so it's not
so boring
but you have to do that
and then he'll lose a half a pound of
two pounds a day
because when you gain weight it's
because you're missing things and you
develop a behavior called pica you just
want to eat and eat and eat and snack
and so forth the medication causes them
to gain weight yeah well that's well
that goes along with that yep
and so
also the
um the brain
requires some stuff here very
specifically so i'd have them take our
synaptive
get two vowels a month of our synaptive
syn
ap tibe synaptiv take three of those
okay twice a day there's two bottles a
month of synaptic
that that gives the brain cells the
nutrients they require to make the
biochemistry to talk to their next-door
neighbors
brain cells okay so between the eggs
and the cholesterol
you want the cholesterol okay do not
take statin drugs cannot take statin
drugs or lower cholesterol yeah okay
don't do that
and um let's see here
the synaptic would be a good one uh
let's let's go here let's go there and
then call us every couple of weeks
because this i've seen people really
they've been institutionalized just like
i was gonna be institutionalized when i
was nine years old
and i healed myself in three days just
getting off the bad stuff
and you know eating the animal foods
with the vitamins and minerals and
that's how i figured it out when i was
nine
all right
okay and so i had very similar problems
but i was in addition to having
mental issues
and and
you know not doing real well in school
but i was very violent and aggressive
and if somebody would even smile at me
i'd beat him up
okay so i know i know what your son is
going through yeah
okay okay so do call us because he's
going to have a great story
now i have one more question sure
um
i was diagnosed with breast cancer last
year i'm clear now um caught it early
but i'm on an estrogen blocker
and i can't have boron in my supplements
according to the nutritionist i'm sure
you can't have what
boron b.o.r
okay
and so i was wondering what you would
recommend for um keeping my bones strong
because i know with a estrogen blocker
it can
affect my bones and joints
yes
okay
um that's a difficult one what i would
do is get a hair analysis get our book
rare earthman cures get a hair analysis
and let's see where your boron is at
okay
um
because
when we when you have a multiple
um
nutrient program
uh you know like our plant minerals has
78 minerals in there including boron how
do you get boron out of there with 78
minerals yeah so let's see let's see
what your boron level is in your hair if
it's
in the normal range or low then we're
not going to worry about it it's
extremely high
her hair analysis
no
because he he doesn't know he's going
gonna just say now just we'll take a
blood sample you know right
no no no no it's these labs i get the
book chapter 10 tells you how to cut the
hair how to box it up or to ship it
don't forget
it gives you how much you check and they
will within two weeks you get to get two
things back you get a chart on all your
nutritional minerals including boron
okay
and they should be kind of you know like
this kind of a little bit all over the
place
but
if they're all low if they're all below
the bottom line that means you're not
absorbing
okay
okay so you don't you don't need to ask
the doctor to interpret it
all right that that is it tells you in
the book
okay rare original here's how to
interpret it and then it has a separate
chart for toxic minerals
like lead and mercury and uranium and
all that kind of stuff
okay
okay because boron is a required
nutrient
it's kind of like saying no more iron
for you
no more iron for you
okay i'm being a smart alex there i mean
that's how stupid it is
no more iron for you
it's an essential nutrient what do you
mean no more iron yeah i get you right
okay but
when doctors don't know things and
obviously they did a good job but it
helps you because you know you're in
remission at least okay and so that's a
good thing
so i have to thank him for putting in
remission
but and so
you can say i'm checking out my boron
levels
okay and when i get to when i get the
charts back from the lab i'll
i'll email you a copy
and educate them a little bit all right
okay okay
okay
thank you thank you
and then call us when you get all your
materials back okay again that book uh
you can go to
uh let's see here
um miss rebecca i can tell you how to
get that book rare earth's been cures
how would they get the book ms rebecca
yes we have it on
askdoclive.com we have a tab just for
you dr wallach and your publications so
okay okay all
all right thank you terry
thank you
now
dr wallach we have a couple questions in
the chat
and marie wants to know what do you
think about phytates
okay phytates block
absorption
okay what what foods have phytates in
them which ones should we eliminate or
or
okay well phytates phytates are found in
high fiber
um
vegetation
okay high fiber vegetation
is where you find phytates
okay
and so
um
it's one of those things where you know
this is one of the things that vegans
will suffer from
because all they eat is vegetables
okay and grains
and so
you'll find phytates in the bran
and grains and stuff like that that's in
addition
to the gluten
okay so you want to stay away from the
high fiber
plant materials
okay
so with that whenever if if you're
taking or or eating something that does
have phytates
would you recommend having maybe two
hours
before or after
taking your supplements just to prevent
any type of hindrance there
no when people eat phytates every day i
wanted to go shopping for a coffin
because they're going to need one early
all right i don't think you can be any
plainer than that doc so thank you so
much yeah it's one of those it's one of
those things where you don't want to say
well you can eat a little bit of poison
you know
that makes total sense
so
you heard it from the good doctor folks
let's
stay away from phytates and you can
always do a google and see what foods
are high in phytates because they are
preventing the absorption of needed
minerals
that your body
has to have in order to thrive
now just a reminder if you are on with
us live go ahead and find that option to
raise your hand you can ask dr wallach
questions
um
and
i
have some questions here in the chat i
have
questions in
that we're going to be getting to also
and dr wallach everything is absolutely
fine
so i know that you're worried about
background noise and we can't
sorry about the background movie oh we
can't hear it we can't hear any
background noise okay okay all is good
so item a
is writing in and she's writing in in
regards to or on behalf of her sister
her sister is five foot three inches
120 pounds
80 years young
uh recently diagnosed with four stage
four colon cancer
she had a tumor removed from her colon
last august
along
with her appendix and about five inches
of colon on either side
just to be sure
i love that just to be sure no
um and a few lymph nodes for biopsies
there was no sign of any more cancer
so she and surgeon thought they had
gotten it all
now there's another tumor on the rectal
muscle
and several nodes on the inside of the
abdominal lining surgery not highly
recommended
now dr wallach
you found that when certain nutrients
are missing
disease and breakdown occur
share with us what you would recommend
for nutritional supplements for item a
sister
okay it's one of those things where
cancer
is a
just a second here there's so much
movement in the background i i
need some quiet here
so
like i said dr wallace we can't hear
so go ahead that's one nice thing about
your headset oh my gosh
okay
i but i'm seeing all this movement on
the screen
okay
and so anyway um yeah they need to stay
away from all the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens no wheat powder i know so sugar
no carbon or drinks even the diet one's
got to go
and it's one of those things where
where
um
you know people don't realize it they
say well you know i'm just eating gluten
one meal a week
well it's just like shooting yourself in
the head one day a week
okay don't do that okay because
it doesn't take much to interfere with
normal
physiology it doesn't take much to
interfere with normal physiology just
think a gluten
makes all those villi disappear so you
cannot absorb nutrition which is
required for your immune system to
defend you against cancer defend you
against viruses covenanting and so forth
and you think you're you're well you
know i only eat pancakes twice a week
i only have spaghetti wednesday nights
after church and so
again i i can't stress it enough
that you can't toy with this you say
okay
this gal here is 80 years old which is
very good because 75 is the average life
expectancy in the united states now
so
is she going to live to be 100
maybe
okay maybe
but i
i think she would live a lot longer and
she'd be a lot more comfortable and not
have to have surgeries and all this kind
of stuff which is risky in somebody of
her age
it's one of those things where
you have to appreciate that um
um
the the importance
of
consistency
of good stuff flowing in
and the absence of bad stuff
okay
and the more you can eliminate the bad
stuff
and the more you can do the good stuff
the more likely you are to add 25 to 50
healthier life
and if it isn't important to spend those
25 to 50 healthy years of the people you
love then go ahead and
go ahead and eat fried eggs for
breakfast go ahead and have spaghetti
every wednesday night go ahead and have
waffles for breakfast go ahead and have
flour tortillas for lunch you know but
they're so good well okay
just you know enjoy yourself because
you're going to cut 25 to 50 healthy
years off july
people say well oh hey she died so young
she died
well that's totally unnecessary because
the good lord you know even in the old
testament they said and man's years
shall be 120.
okay so this is not difficult
it's just a choice people make a choice
do you just put dirt from texas in your
car
and hope there's oil in it come on it's
dirt from texas there's bound to be some
oil why should i pay three dollars a
quart for oil
you wouldn't do that to your car
so why do you do that to yourself
if you take care of yourself as good as
you take care of your car you can add 25
to 50 healthy ears your life
it is not difficult but you do have to
be persistent consistent
and
and say you know i apologize i just
don't go to those places so you guys
have fun
but i'm going to stay home
and i'm going to have you know i make my
own salad
i'm going to have some
alaska tuna packed in water
and i'm going to
for dessert i'm gonna have some
gluten-free ice cream
and um i'm gonna have a glass of red
wine which is made from
grapes and berries
i'm not gonna have beer made from wheat
by the right oats
okay and so
you know you can kind of try to educate
them backhandedly so just say what
you're doing
and they'll say you know you know
grandma
um
rebecca here she's 120 years old and
she's still out there playing tennis
okay
how does she do that oh it must be the
good genes in her family no
it's how
okay how grandma rebecca is doing all
the good stuff
that's what what happens here you have
to do the good stuff only
don't even say i you know i don't even
like to talk about the bad stuff
okay because when you talk about people
say well there's room for
you know some other opinions well that's
true
it's true you can either believe in god
or not
you either believe in going the speed
limit or not
okay you can believe in having all your
90 essential nutrients or not
and see who wins at the end of the game
so i think that's the best answer i can
give for that one
all right thank you so much dr wallach
how about deprivation chambers we've had
a question in regards to a deprivation
chamber and is that beneficial
do you know okay yeah i'm assuming that
this is somebody who is very sensitive
to light and to
noise and
to crowds and all this kind of stuff and
so they're you know they respond to
what's going on in the environment
and so they're they you know their
neurologists put them in these chambers
um for an hour a day or whatever to get
a quiet time
and ptsd is the specific
condition that this person is con
concerned with
okay ptsd
yeah post-traumatic stress syndrome okay
kind of thing
okay yeah they may have had a loss a
terrible loss in a family in a car wreck
or suicide or something like that and
they may be you know looking in the
mirror and saying was i responsible for
that okay military
military okay all those kind of things
and so um yeah i spent
spent 27 years in the military i saw
everything seven years
in the artillery
um
fort leonard wood in missouri
105's 155 howitzers went all over the
world primarily europe uh training our
boys and girls in our our
um forts all around the world
particularly europe and then i spent 20
years in the air force
primarily in the pacific
and all the asian countries including
hawaii okay
and
we still have a great great great
um
connection with the philippines and
australia and new zealand
uh hawaii of course
um
let's see here
[Music]
taiwan um we're working with korea
uh hong kong
china japan
and so
you know i've seen it all
i've seen it all i retired as lieutenant
colonel in the air force
so you can imagine me being all over the
place all over the world with every kind
of
weapon and food and diet and environment
you can see
in the world i've been exposed to that
and so it's one of those things where
i've seen everything you can see
and i've seen every result
okay and so it's a uniform
the point that i'm getting at it's
uniform it's predictable it's
predictable
that if you do everything right you're
going to maximize your health the
quality of your life and the length of
your life if you don't pay attention to
details you're going out every wednesday
night and every friday night drinking
beer with the boys and girls
and not paying attention to what you're
drinking
okay and you're getting all that gluten
in your beer
and your
spaghetti and whatever else you're
eating or flour tortillas whatever
you're eating
and so and
you just had a great time
but then you die at 58.
and so are you prepared to give up 50
years of your life
because you have fun on friday night
having beer with the boys
that's everybody's option and so
most of these doctors who are involved
with these sort of issues
um
they really don't tell these folks
why they got this way they just say well
this is what you got and here's our
treatment
and they do get some temporary relief of
their concerns
uh when you do all these weird things
and so the the patient is happy until
they die at 58.
all right thank you so much dr wallick
let's go to the next town that is up
sarita go ahead and unmute yourself
okay serena can we help you
can you hear me yes ma'am
okay great hi dr wallace hi everybody
hi
okay so i'm working with a gentleman
right now and actually he's a
chiropractor
and he has a bulging disc so i'm getting
him introduced to the product so he just
filled it out his health evaluation
so a bulging disc he had he said he got
it when he was playing sports so he does
come sometime have a lot of pain so what
would you suggest for him
okay you know how much he weighs and how
old is he yeah let me pull up his report
real quick he weighs
um
weighs 220 he's 6 1
33 years old
okay
yeah yeah even chiropractors have bones
and correlation ligaments and tendons
and connective tissue
and even chiropractors
have to take the 90 essential nutrients
if they're going to maximize the
longevity and benefit and health
and function of all their body parts
including the disc
okay
just taking an adjustment is not going
to solve the problem
you know an adjustment will not solve a
vitamin d3 deficiency an adjustment will
not
um
solve a
calcium deficiency an adjustment will
not solve
collagen peptide deficiency and so on
okay yeah so a 200 okay so 200 pounds
okay
uh this guy
needs to get rid of all those bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils or gluten the weep around those
sugar no carbohydrate drinks that one's
got to go
because a
the carbonation of the diet drinks
neutralize stomach acid which is
required to absorb minerals and digest
food
and
um even chiropractors will benefit from
a program okay
um yeah and so
he needs two healthy brain and heart
packs per month
two healthy brain and heart pattern a
month to photos everything twice a day i
want him to get two bottles a month of
our msm so you can take three at
breakfast three at lunch at dinner time
and they're gonna support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
the bone itself
and um we're only going to charge him
wholesale if he gets on auto ship we'll
we'll pay the shipping for him
okay then he needs a collagen peptides a
scoop of that collagen peptides in his
morning drink and still
peptides in the evening drink
okay that'll support his immune system
and his bone marrow
and the connective tissue in his skin
is the tendons and ligaments connective
tissue is disc
arteries and veins and so forth
uh he also needs vitamin d3 three of
those twice it has two bowels a month
and let's see here if he has
um stuff going on you know
if he's got things you know like pain
and numbness and tingling and stuff down
his legs tories obviously got some
um
because of his disc issue you know he's
getting on a nerve sciatic nerve squeeze
he's got peripheral neuropathies and so
forth he should also take our synaptic
take three of those twice a day and
that'll help
his brain and nerve cells do their jobs
better
all right
and um
i'm trying to think here uh for pain
topically we have our cm cream you can
apply the same cream topically to any
place that hurts we'll give them about
two hours of pain relief we also have
our um let's see our hemp fx our soothed
okay that um
it can be placed topically
and it'll give you about four hours of
pain relief so i like to use the same
cream during the day and then a half
hour before bedtime uses soothe from our
hemp fx
and that will
you know really really
resolve the pain issue
and within
um anywhere from two to six eight weeks
all this issue should be resolved and so
the question comes
how long
should this chiropractor be taking our
program with all these nutrients
oh he should be taking it for the rest
of his life
how long does this chiropractor need
oxygen
how long does a chiropractor need water
how long does a chiropractor need
protein
and so
a lot of people including healers
whether they're chiropractors or an
atrium doctors or medical doctors or
do's or nurses
okay
uh physical therapists
they
misbelieve okay because they say okay
well you're okay now you you know stop
taking your nutritional program
you know you run out you don't need art
anymore well then within three months
time they're back down the hole yeah
well that didn't work i'm back here now
because my problems back is 10 times
worse now that was
okay
well that's because you're acting like
you're acting when you're doing okay and
you're not getting the nutrients anymore
and so it's like running on a flat tire
what's going to happen after about five
miles of running on a flat tire
well that that metal wheel is going to
chew that tire up and you're not going
to be able to use it anymore
you're going to fly a tire you need to
change to the
spare tire immediately that way you can
repair that tire
got it
yes sir got it all right don't don't
don't forget the don't forget the
antifreeze
don't forget the oil don't forget the
gasoline don't forget the heavy grease
okay the car requires a lot of stuff
yes
absolutely thank you dr alex yeah well
let's let's have this chiropractor let's
have him be an example and you know as
he goes along here you know get him get
him on this show with us we'd like to
answer his questions and educate him so
he can carry on this you sponsor him in
your organization
okay and let's get going with this guy
okay yeah i'm dripping i'm dripping him
along so that's the plan
okay very good
bye bye thank you
bye-bye
awesome sarita thank you so much great
questions yeah
dr wellick we have another question this
one's coming from nasima
one of our amazing co-hosts
so nasima's first question just two is
in regards to deep vein thrombosis it is
is it the same as arterial sclerosis
no
okay d vein thrombosis
d vein thrombosis is caused by a very
specific nutritional deficiency
okay thrombosis is a blood clot
when you have
plaque in your arteries
that scar tissue lining the inside
lining of the arteries okay
and doctors mistakenly said it was
caused by cholesterol no it's caused by
eating
heated oils like fried foods and that
kind of stuff and salad dressings and so
on
and your body responds to that
inflammation caused by those oils
by putting connective tissue in places
that are irritated well your blood
vessels are irritated
by those oils
oxidizing
and turning into trans fats
heterocycline acrylamides
and they made a mistake thinking that it
was
um and professing that it was
cholesterol and so boy all the all the
pharmaceutical companies came out with
statin drugs the lower cholesterol we're
going to save the world from plaque in
the artery they came out with statin
drugs and in 1960 they got a new disease
as a result of this
cholesterol-lowering drugs okay
oh it's called alzheimer's disease
alzheimer's disease is caused by a
cholesterol
deficiency
your brain
is it has a significant amount of
cholesterol of course we talked about
this at the beginning tonight
or this afternoon this morning wherever
you're at in the world
um
this is um
ms
okay
um
and all kinds of memory problems but
then now we come up with alzheimer's
disease alzheimer's disease is caused by
statin drugs 1960 there was no such
thing as alzheimer's disease until the
statin drugs were put on the market and
doctors went crazy giving everybody
including embryos statin drugs
and and so it's one of those things
where
uh it was a big big big
error on on
the
backs and necks and heads
uh
and responsibilities of the medical
system
okay because
um the plaque in the arteries was not
caused by
cholesterol when they came out with a
statin drugs or lower cholesterol they
created a whole new
version of disease called alzheimer's
disease and it's kind of a variation
on it's all in your head and it's a
variation on
also
um
let's see here msm
uh
the ms multiple sclerosis there there
you go multiple sclerosis where you lose
the
white matter the brain because you're
not taking in cholesterol because you're
taking statin drugs
and so a lot of this is uh
when i say self-inflicted i mean in
humanity
if you know you're eating rabbits and
squirrels and fish and
and
beef and chickens and liver and all that
kind of stuff every week then you're not
going to have these diseases but when
you're avoiding those things because
doctors say oh they have cholesterol and
you can't have don't eat liver
don't do that
okay well liver is one of your best
foods
it has
it has 40 nutrients in it and before the
days of vitamin mineral tablets and
capsules and pills and drinks
the liver
was the best
best source of
vitamins and minerals because that's
where your body stores them in the liver
and so yeah you know i used to fight to
get the chicken livers okay when we
would kill our chickens and eat them
everybody else you eat the drumstick i
just want the livers
and so that helps a lot
well dr wallach if somebody has blood
clots
say a gentleman 30 years old 5 foot 10
200 pounds he's on blood centers
what would you recommend
supplement wise in order to address
blood clots that are in the in one leg
but not both
well it doesn't matter whether it's one
leg or both legs
okay it doesn't matter if it's in one of
your internal
veins or arteries in your brain and your
uh coronary arteries or coronary veins
and stuff like that it doesn't matter
we're getting a blood clot it's all due
to the same thing this is a nutritional
deficiency blood clots are caused by
nutritional deficiency the good lord
gave us everything we needed
to prevent blood clots in our food
but you have to eat the food
okay uh you can't fry it and that kind
of stuff and so you know
um
and and if you don't want to eat liver
just take more of our
essential factors okay
and that's why we have the healthy brain
and heart pack 215 nutrients and
contains the nutrients
that will prevent and reverse blood
clots people say well which one is it
which one is it i used to tell people
which one it was
and they'd run to the grocery store and
they'd buy that one nutrient they'd take
it and then they would die
from hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease which is not due to blood clots
due to a mineral deficiency but if they
would take
the 90 or take the healthy brain and
heart pack which is 215
then they wouldn't have either those
issues
okay
and so i learned that if you want to get
that information that's why we have the
book rarism and cures that's why i have
the book epigenetics that's why we have
the book and the cd and the dvd set the
truth about nutrition
we have the book that's all in your head
we have the book
dr wells cooking about the bad foods we
have the book epigenetics
and
uh
right now i'll see here miss rebecca and
i were working on a cd
that's going to go it's going to be
attached to
the book it's all in your head
be titled the same title it's all in
your head
it goes into
ms multiple sclerosis it goes into
these sorts of things that are caused by
nutritional deficiencies
cholesterol deficiencies
but cholesterol deficiently my doctor
says cholesterol causes heart attacks no
you need to get a different doctor your
doctor doesn't know what he's talking
about
and then they go to different doctors
say well you have the metabolic syndrome
what's the metabolic syndrome well
that's just something doctors made up as
metabolic syndromes made out of
let's see here
we're looking at high blood pressure
diabetes
we're looking at heart disease we're
looking at obesity all these things are
people things that you know about we
have preventions for and
programs reverse these things
but doctors call it the metabolic
syndrome because the average american
public
because of efforts you know
like um
what we're doing here
uh with uh um
uh rebecca and her team
okay every friday morning
it's one of those things where
um if everybody would do that we
eliminate
like 50 different diseases
okay or maybe more maybe a hundred
different diseases
and this is not difficult
but people keep well my doctor said i
just love that when they beat their
chest and stand on something like
superman or tarzan my doctor says
i've got the metabolic syndrome
well
are you bragging or complaining
but they can't call these diseases
genetic anymore because they're proven
they're not they can't call them
autoimmune anymore because we've proven
they're not
they're simple nutritional deficient
diseases so they came up let's take a
collection of these things we'll call
them the metabolic syndrome because they
tend to run together and they sound so
scientific it sounds so medical
metabolic syndrome oh my gosh
okay so that's what that's all about
all right thank you so much dr wallace
next question is in regards to
a little boy
two years old
[Music]
nine months weighs 30 pounds he doesn't
have any diagnosis yet because they say
he's too young but
uh and he's not on any medications
they're limiting his sugar because the
parents feel that he may have
adhd
and
he's
has bundles of energy
struggles to sit still
talks more or less all the time from
wake to sleep trouble
concentrating switches toys and games
frequently the brain is all over the
place
he's fearless there's no concept of
danger or harm
he has no social skills to play with
other children
and cannot tell right from wrong that
most kids his age can
what should they do
in regards to his diet and
supplementation well he they need to get
a different pediatrician okay because
this kid
is super nutritiously deficient i
guarantee that he's having an oatmeal
for breakfast every morning or wheaties
breakfast is champions or cheerios
he's having waffles pancakes gluten
gluten gluten gluten gluten gluten and
he's not taking if he is taking a
supplement probably vitamin c or
something like that or or some baby
vitamin with vitamin a and some b1 and
that kind of stuff
okay not really getting any serious
minerals okay
so um you say he weighs um
30 pounds correct 30 pounds okay i want
him to get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no gluten no we brought rhinos no sugar
no carbohydrate or drinks
either that one's got to go i want him
to have
um one soft
um
scrambled egg and butter twice a day
once a breakfast once at dinner time
then i also want him to have rice he
needs to eat like an asian he can have
rice for breakfast and rice for lunch
you have rice for dinner
but none of the bad stuff not even once
a year okay not on christmas okay not on
his birthday no no no
okay
and then he can have sweet potatoes and
he can have tomatoes and onions and
um
you know cauliflower and that kind of
stuff
okay then i want him also to have
our kids toddy
one of them our kids toddy and the
dosage rate for him is on the back label
by pound of body weight
okay it tastes good it tastes like
lemonade so he's going to like it tastes
very nice
but it has
it's a complete liquid supplement for
kids kids toddy then we want them also
to have the cherry mints
use that same dosage rate if you know
some you know um an ounce per this
amount of weight or a half ounce for
this amount of value a teaspoon for this
amount of weight and so forth is the
same
weight dosage schedule that's on the
back of the kid's toddy then he also
needs the efas
i only have one efa twice a day and one
efa plus twice a day and if he's not
into chewing them and swallowing them
because they're soft shell capsules
with those essential fats in them um
what you can do is puncture the
these capsules and squirt them into the
kids toddy
okay
one each of the efa and efa plus is
breakfast and dinner
okay and that's going to work a lot
and let's see here
um
also wouldn't hurt for him also to have
our liquid z radical he can also have
that
and again use that same dosage schedule
of the z radical
it has a lot of minerals from the ocean
and
it's one of those things very kids like
it but it's a very very useful thing
when you have all these emotional things
okay
all right thank you so much dr wallach
the next question that's coming up um
curie's father
god bless him
he is um or
retired army pharmacist lieutenant
colonel
very smart 75 years old approximately
175 pounds
unfortunately he believes in
prescriptions and he has a recent
diagnosis of alzheimer's
so
he says he's not sure he believes in
nutrition but will consider it which
that's a plus that's a win that he'll
consider
so she wants to know
what
would she recommend
so he is vested um
but
medical prescriptions have failed him so
he's been on the top alzheimer's drugs
and for a couple years and due to
concern of his brother and family
history
he's open to try something else
okay well alzheimer's not a genetic
thing it's not an immune thing
um it can be family old because if
everybody's eating the same way you know
and taking the same statin drugs you got
to get off of statin drugs
and he's got to eat three eggs twice a
day with soft yolks soft boiled soft
yolks salt poached soft yolks soft salt
scrambled butter that's how i have mine
i only weigh 142 pounds okay
and um then he also needs two healthy
brain and heart packs per month two
healthy brain and heart patch month
photo sitting twice a day if he's a
brave lieutenant colonel
okay then he'll be able to do that he
also needs two bottles a month of our
msm so you can take three breakfasts
three of the lunches dinner time and
they will support and promote mains
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between
vertebrae bone makes bone himself
then he needs the
um i want to take the collagen peptides
you take three of those
another let me pack up a scoop of the
collagen peptides at breakfast and just
drink a scoop of collagen peptides and
drink in the evening time you also need
three of the vitamin d3 capsules of
breakfast three at dinner time they're
going to help absorb the minerals and
put them into the right places
he might have osteoporosis of the skull
additionally okay in addition to memory
issues
it may not really be alzheimer's disease
but he got memory issues
and then but he does have to get off of
statin drugs i mean like immediately not
not
you know he called turkey off the
stanton drug because there's going to be
residual in his body for a couple of
weeks even if he gets cold turkey off
and then he needs to
let's see here take our
synaptive you take three of those twice
a day that's two bottles a month
they
provide the nutrition for brain cells
that allow them to make the
biochemistries they talk to their
neighbor cells okay
and also the de-stress capsules
i want him to take three of those twice
a day that's good for the brain function
also
and let's see here
um
we have memory fx he can take memory
effects through those twice as two
bottles a month
and you know he might say well this
awful lot of pills okay well
then enjoy your alzheimer's
yeah it's simple if you fight it it
makes it more difficult and prolongs the
symptoms
so dr wallach curie also has a question
in regards to what would be the ideal
weight for a female
six foot one
she's 55 years old but passes for 40.
so what would be an ideal weight for a
six foot one female
okay
um can see here she could be
um 160
okay
and you know i deal with a lot of
basketball players both men and women
so i deal with a lot of
women who are
six foot tall five foot ten to
some of them are close to seven foot
tall okay
and so um but they do have to
take their nutrients according to their
body weight not their height but their
body weight
and
this is not difficult but they do need
to take them especially if they're
exercising or doing you know home work
or working in the gardens and working up
a sweat and so forth but
it's one of those things where yep you
do have to take all 90.
in the old days they did it by
uh and of course it wasn't the same
everywhere because they're putting wood
ashes into their gardens and again
nutritional minerals are not occurring
in uniform blank around the crest of
yours so some wood ashes had three
minerals in them some wood ashes had
five somewhat ashes had eight some wood
ashes had ten somewhat ashes had
eighteen somewhat actually had twenty
five some had forty
very rarely did they have all sixty and
this is these places on earth where the
people live to be 100 110 120 130 140
these are the places where people live a
long time
because
because of volcanoes
glaciers volcanoes and all that kind of
stuff
these minerals are there
and they're growing their own food
they're not importing food so they're
getting those minerals from the volcanic
ash
and so this is why they do live a long
time
all right thank you so much dr wallach
can you believe two hours are gone
already
well i have so much fun dealing with you
and your team rebecca every friday and
of course uh the the people who call in
i consider our family
and so you know we have this huge family
all over the world 80 countries now
and um
you hear just about every health problem
you can think of and a lot of health
problems you don't hear about much often
and it's because misinformation they're
given by the medical system they're
given misinformation in many cases
they're not given any information at all
from from their health classes at school
or their science classes at school so
they just sort of
kind of hit and miss it based on
what they read on you know the back of
the label of some candy bar or something
like that and so it's it's really a sad
sad sad sad thing
it is really sad where people get their
information and believe
you know whatever they read or whatever
they hear whatever they see as being
truth without looking into
sources actual research yep
so you have so many books that share
actual research
dr wallach
um it's incredible to to be able to see
boxes and boxes of
just books waiting to go into the hands
of individuals that need them so
so badly
everybody
you have been watching ask doc live on
behalf of myself rebecca duce kozak and
my co-hosts dr judy reynolds heather
bowen jonty mccollier nasim omar and
ruth ellen sanchez and of course
the one and only dr joel wallick
we invite you to feel the difference
and be empowered of your own health
journey by taking your nutrition into
your own hands
the body wasn't made from chemicals and
junk folks
that's our first clue
as to what we need in order to
create recreate and continue
healthy cell generation
we'll see you next time on ask doc live
god bless you rebecca
love you thank you dr wallach
bye everybody